افاد موقع واكسيوس ان مديره وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
قام بزياره سريه الى الصين الشهر الماضي
في مؤشر على مدى قلق البيت الابيض بشان
تدهور العلاقات
ونقل الموقع عن مسؤول امريكي عقد اجتماعات
مع المسؤولين الصينيين حيث اكد على اهميه
الحفاظ على خطوط الاتصال بين البلدين من
خلال قنوات الاستخبارات وامتنع البيت
الابيض وكاله المخابرات المركزيه عن
التعليق لكن المسؤول الامريكي قال ان
بيرنز التقى خلال زياره بمسؤولين في
المخابرات الصينيه حسب اكسيوس وتزملت
زياره برينز لبيجين مع الاجتماع الذي عقده
مستشار الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جيك
سلفن مع وان جي كبير مسؤولي سياسه
الخارجيه الصينيه في العاصمه النمساويه
فيينا في الحادي عشر من مايو ايار الماضي